quinze minutes il faut larguer les
amarres et parti vert
de jour de nuit
au niveau français il fait chaud je mal
à respirer ici
les sauveteurs en mer il donne tout et
ne prennent que les risques une demande
rien en retour cette peur de la mort
elle reste
reste que parents nous et pour nos
familles c'est compliqué toile
[Musique]
salut tout le monde c'est vargas je suis
avec brut à cavalaire et on est venu
nous vous présenter le travail des
sauveteurs au maire qui sauvent des vies
toute l'année bonjour royaux ce prêt
pour son premier entraînement
bienvenue à bord donc là tu abords de la
sns 264 vigie qui équipe la station snsm
de cavalaire
on va commencer déjà pardonné une tenue
aller en classe de changer et puis après
on va débriefer franchement j'appréhende
un g après la france tout court
on va déjà sur la terre ferme avec du
temps des galères alors dans l'eau
moi je suis prêt je sais ce que ça a
donné vie à ça on s'en sert elle est
même plus qu'une bouée c'est un radeau
de survie et tu verras que là quand on
m'a tiré là dessus moment donné où ça va
s'ouvrir matin un petit bateau flottant
ça prend une bonne personne à
l'intérieur
ça dépend pas les six oui des fois plus
suivant la taille du bateau l'eau à la
gto pa aujourd'hui je suis toujours mais
on peut dire qu elle ajouté mais c'est
pas mercal pape apporte avec des
sauveteurs dit quoi chef wattrelos à ses
patrons patron tu peux m'appeler série
la sécu
votre série nascar
voyez crossmen donc je vous disais nous
sortons pour exercice en baie de
cavalaire durée 1h30
là on part sur la legacy d'entraînement
mais pont-à-marcq à tout moment peut
appeler pour faire
une vraie mission de sauvetage pour
fait partie
alors la snsm ça veut dire société
nationale de sauvetage en mer snsm en
fait puise ses racines dans les années
1860 1870 à l'époque qui ont été créés
deux sociétés la société centrale des
naufragés et la société des hospitaliers
sauveteurs bretons et puis il ya 52 ans
exactement
les deux sociétés ont fusionné c'est une
racine dont l'adn et la solidarité des
gens de mer
l'orgasme
il y apparaît
arias mais la main sur la barre et je
suis à côté tu vas suivre un cap visuel
c'est la pointe du cap bon bateau et
dessus tu rattrape un peu par la voilà
nickel ça c'est la première étape wpt à
un équipier on lui demande le savoir
barré pourquoi est-ce que six mois le
patron
il faut que je fasse autre chose que je
parle à radio que j'organise bonne
opération
je vais peut-être délégué il veut dire à
quelqu'un tu tiens ce cap jamais cru web
après on peut le rabaisser avec des
flaps ouest ifrap derrière qui permet de
baisser le battoir c'est un peu plus
délicat à prêt à piloter
on peut se poser leur pouvoir commencer
à regarder un peu là le reste du
matériel
tu tombes dans l'eau même si tu sais
nager
j'étais pas du connaissance même si tu
sais nager tu coules où tu boit la tasse
donc ça ça te garde en vie tu vas
changer de gilles et tu vas messieurs
gilles et là ça c'est un gilet
d'entraînement on a le choix soit tu dis
et je me fous à la baille
il voit ce que ça donne et sa sour soit
tranquille sur le bateau tu veux pas te
mouiller et on va tirer sur les poignets
enregistré d
et alors j'étais à l'opposé à casquette
y a pas de requins en méditerranée ça
risquerait way
[Musique]
à baho
ce match là
le droitier coeur
on va envoyer notre majeur pour
récupérer on va faire comme si tu étais
une vraie victime à l'eau il va aller
directement sur la victime pour
s'assurer qu'elle n'a pas boire la tasse
qu'elle va pas avoir de malaise savoir
si elle est consciente déjà et puis
c'est la patte de traumatisme c'est avec
la sp réitéré que respirer vous
inquiétez pas d'accord je vous ramène à
la vedette c'est important de savoir
combien de temps allait rester dans
l'eau si la personne est en hypothermie
il ya des procédures qui vont être mises
en place et notre nageurs là va rassurer
la personne et poser les petites
questions tout en la ramenant à près de
la vedette
et puis nous on va se préparer c'est
chaud là il n'y a pas de mère tu vois il
n'y a pas de vague mais quand à du vent
quand a forci cette voie force 8
hectares à 90 kilomètres par heure
devant qui t'arrive dessus tu vas être
protégés comme ça après tu veux regarder
à l'intérieur c'est une petite loupiote
là est en fait là il ya un velcro et
comme ça nous comptons pas de chercher
de nuit hop ça s'allume et on va pouvoir
se trouver
il ya 8000 bénévoles qui toute l'année
sont disponibles pour aller porter
secours à nos concitoyens qui se
trouvent en difficulté en mer ou à la
période estivale sur des plages nous ne
sommes pas un service d'état mais nous
accomplirons munitions mission de
service public sous le contrôle de
l'état
non maintenant passer à l'étape
supérieure c'est le radeau de survie
dont clara les bagages ou feraient
semblant d'être les deux naufragés ou
quand vous allez monter à l'intérieur
tout de suite la gauche ou à droite vous
allez trouver un petit couteau ce petit
couteau il va vous servir à couper la
sangle qui vous relie aux bateaux
pourquoi est-ce que le bateau est en
train de couler si les bateaux y coule
et vous emporte avec donc à la sangle a
bien envie de la coupe est une autre
chose importante si jamais ça vous
arrive d'être sur un bateau qui est en
train de couler tout ce qui flotte les
banquettes les serviettes tout ça on met
tous à l'eau pour qu'on soit vu quand on
va envoyer les secours si un avion un
hélico qui passe s'il voit juste un tout
petit point dans la tempête c'est pas
facile si par contre il voit plein de
trucs qui flottent partout il dit
c'est là que le bateau il a coulé alors
faut penser à mettre un maximum de
choses par dessus bord
allez on doit aller attention
mais
je
claire tu sens que c'est lourd palmer
qui depuis michel puisque j'en peux plus
la démonologie je me sens mal à l'aise
[Musique]
oui les parties où est parti dans l'eau
au à l'écran mais la troisième place et
elle souligné on va tout est terrible et
donc sur les trois feux à main qu'elle a
essayé déclenché aucun des trois n'a
fonctionné qu'à on se rend compte de
l'importance fondamentale de faire
réviser tous les ans au matériel de
sécurité
allez maintenant on va aller les
chercher calme on est sympa il faut
entretenir son poteau il faut dire où on
va il faut connaître son bateau il faut
être capable de réparer une petite panne
qui arrivent il faut bien regarder la
météo
voilà des courants connaître et voilà
sur les précautions élémentaires à
prendre et moi j'en appelle à la
responsabilité de tous ceux qui
fréquentaient mais il faut que la mère
reste un plaisir
or la mer si on ne la respecte pas la
mère peut être très vite dangereuse
bonjour monsieur nous sommes les
sauveteurs en mer on vient vous porter
assistance nous allons envoyer un nageur
à bord du radeau de survie pour venir
vous chercher
conditions
bonjour on peut remonter à mort
d'abord la marche ici
c'est le match des verts kramer ok on
remonte le radeau et on va le faire
embarquer à bord c'est facile pas touche
allez on maintient le radeau je pensais
pas qu'on aura une victime et non six
mois j'étais mou à balawi chaleur à
l'intérieur c'est difficile c'était en
tout 45 degrés ou quoi internet peut
respirer
les fumigènes ils ont pas marcher quand
par hasard dans la merde là
je donne un radeau de survie
ça c'est ce qui est vital ces lots en
fait le corps humain 72 heures on peut
tenir sans eau
c'est pour ça que c'est pas une grosse
bourde et que c'est les petites rations
faut la prendre petit à petit pour tenir
le plus longtemps possible et ça c'est
super important l'eponge pour les choses
qu'on va faire c'est que on va cesser
doit y ait de l'eau à l'intérieur quand
on monte
il faut que ça soit sec si on a des
vêtements mouillés il faut les enlever
les potées remis ça va très très vite
ensuite c'est des petits médicaments et
là on a vu que notre ami a eu un petit
mal de mer ça arrive vite le mal de mer
ça peut devenir très très compliqué
voire insupportable il y en a même
certains qui se jette à l'eau
tellement qu'ils ne peuvent pas
supporter le mal de mer assez physique a
un petit peu à la survie c'est pas
facile ça veut bien dire ce que ça veut
dire survie passe quand tu es stressé
c'est
des perdus
avec la chaleur les facs ah ouais tu
peux
vite connaissance en toile évitant way
c'est pour ça qu'on est là allez on va a
marre et on va partir vous êtes des gens
on va rentrer au port
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
opérations difficiles oui l'opération
difficile on est plusieurs en avoir vécu
qui sont bien terminées des fois où on
était content même si c'était très
compliqué on l'avait sauvé les gens et
puis j'ai eu des fois où même pour nous
c'est devenu compliqué et quant à ta
femme et tes filles x 10 3 heures du
matin et du vent si les parties à sait
que c'est compliqué donc là en général
donc n'étaient pas rentrés tap a envoyé
un sms pour dire c'est bon les allers
retours bison l'ouest qui savent pas ce
qui se passe une image terrible cette
vedette de la snsm la société nationale
de sauvetage en mer
retourner sur le rivage des sables
d'olonne l'embarcation a chaviré alors
qu'elle portait au secours d'un bateau
de pêche à son bord sept bénévoles trois
sont morts un pêcheur est lui aussi
porté disparu ce soir c'est le drame
qu'on redoute tous on espère que
s'arrête jamais et puis quand ça arrive
pas on est tous touchés c'est vraiment
un deuil pour nous c'est d'une parce
qu'on se projette pas ce qu'on se dit
que ça peut nous arriver et deux parce
que là on est tous quelque part un peu
tous des frères donc c'est les frères
qu'on a permis à paraître tous les jours
dans un bateau partager des liens forts
ouais ouais ça c'est vrai c'est quelque
chose qui nous une dizaine tout à fait
et ça ça ne va tous un pacte et en même
temps ça nous soude
ça nous motive encore plus à être
déterminée à sauver des gens et ça fait
partie des risques du métier
et même si on les bénévoles ça reste ça
reste une passion il est bien content de
se dire que voilà on va sauver des gens
c'est une passion du bénévolat est donc
tout ça c'est vrai que c'est beau ça ne
motive pas en reste si le courage merci
c'est vous merci à vous merci merci
d'être là voilà et donc j'espère que là
on taille ont fait découvrir s'appuie
avec les différentes interviews tout ça
c'est des petits coups de projecteurs
combler sur la snsm
ça va sensibiliser encore plus les paies
dossier pour faire des dons pour nous
soutenir
et pour motiver des jeunes à venir à
embarquer avec nous à avoir la même
passion que nous battons je menais
20minutes engagé dans
salt à jamais alors moi ça fait
plusieurs années que je faisais
sauveteurs junior c'est une association
qui entraîne les jeunes à partir de 10
ans à faire du sauvetage en mer est un
site de sabha à majorité
du coup j'ai voulu intégrer la snsm et
là ça fait à peu près un mois que je
viens d'intégrer la snsm donc une jeune
recrue ses parents il en pense quoi que
tu prennes la même j'apprenne berry bas
ils sont je pense qu'ils sont fiers de
moi et que même si c'est risqué il sauf
que je peux que je fais pas des trucs
inconscient inconsciemment non plus
j'ai rencontré des personnes
extraordinaires parce que des personnes
bénévoles qui s'occupent de surveiller
les maires si on a des pépins on est
bien content qu'il soit là ils font des
sacrifices ils sont bénévoles comme je
le dis ils ont des familles à la maison
ils ont leur famille ils ont leurs
enfants
donc ils sacrifient tout pour sauver des
gens donc ça fait ça fait chaud au coeur
et que leurs camarades débats y perdre
père de vie dans des accidents parce que
ça arrive c'est pas tout beau tout rose
donc
on attendrait spa et voilà ça me touche
c'est des grandes personnes
et